a full minute of logos horror sequel
goes back in time cliche this picture is
different from the first insidious and
yeah they had to change the actor which
is fine but the demon is standing by the
car here when in the first one it was
just a reflection in the windshield and
he's afraid guy who doesn't want the
mother to know when he's saying
whisper-yell so she can easily hear it
if there were videos of these same
moments he would not be able to
distinguish them from the photographs
because this is the extent of the
demon's abilities I'd like to try
something with you Josh and I promise it
won't hurt you mean speaking with your
real voice rather than the obvious lin
shaye overdub getting into Josh's dream
will require the lighting of
approximately 1 million candles are you
alone no she's hypnotized Josh please
the pronoun game so that Elise has to
ask who the hell she is I'll walk around
the house and you tell me if I'm getting
warmer or colder child who doesn't want
to give away the demons location is
fooled into thinking it won't be mad as
long as Elise has to work for it who are
you what do you want I just want a photo
bomb I thought everybody knew that
demon with this kind of power has a
horrible time possessing children for
some reason can you stop it I could take
away his gift to suppress his memory of
his ability because I have the
neuralyzer from men in black and the
trolls from frozen in my car and if that
doesn't work I'll use the obliviate
spell talk to me by one Hermione Granger
after 10 minutes of actual movie movie
grinds to a halt with two-minute opening
credits sequence might as well put a
credit in there that says it's okay to
get concessions now Rose Byrne isn't my
girlfriend in this scene although she's
kind of busy talking to a cop so as soon
as her murder rap is in the clear
I'm reserving the right to be mad she's
not my girlfriend and whatever scene
that is previously on insidious even if
Josh just lost the demon none of his
actions make sense he's walking into a
room sees a clearly dead person sitting
in a chair he walks in like what's for
dinner honey
this is a photo at least took seconds
before she was killed which if the first
movie is to be believed
is a picture of a demon lady who killed
her so why are they worried about Josh
shouldn't they be looking for an evil
witch lady already Elise has marks on
her neck that will put there by human
hands I'll let you know if forensics
matches those marks to your husband they
never show this picture in the first
movie or in this scene is it Josh
lunging at the camera with a demon lady
behind him or is it just the demon lady
and the first movie we see a reenactment
of what happened but we don't see what
the camera actually took a picture of if
it's just this then the cops are pinning
this on the husband for virtually no
reason other than they saw in the first
insidious in theatres child who just
went through some horrific she is now
reading the turn of the screw before
bedtime demon follows the Paranormal
Activity to model and takes the baby out
of the crib but loses all power to do
anything after that
maybe she climbed out of her crib maybe
you missed the part when I said the
piano was playing all by itself actually
it's amazing when we see Josh's weird
behavior that Renee doesn't think he's
still possessed
paper-rock-scissors mods how does this
guy know we want to fast-forward through
all this oh also movie again cuts away
from the crucial moment in 1986 so we
can see some more demon tomfoolery
everyone's addicted to horror movies and
books after the events of the first
insidious children's toys are
irresistible to evil spirits also I'm
sitting the children's toy industry for
making these abominations don't mind me
just ghost in through the background you
in for some Thai food later say no to
drugs ghosts
foreshadowing mmm-hmm previously on
insidious chapter 2 since Lorraine saw
that ghosts later why didn't she see the
ghosts when she was in Dalton's bedroom
daddy mom no denial I'm gonna take the
boys to school I'm totally a demon
stance oh yeah the image yeah but how
did you know something was back there
the first time you watch this you
pointed like you saw something when you
clearly couldn't see anything until you
lighten the image
it's that Josh it's not because the
murder suspect in the photo is a woman
seriously this thing now I'm not gonna
lie if I saw this in real life it would
freak me the fuck out but on a little
down on this ghost song choice this
seems a little cliche for me it's like
an American Idol in someone bust out
Edwin McCain zombie ghost disappears
like a dick and then continues the song
in the baby's room my question is why
didn't it just do that in the first
place instead of appearing on the couch
like some sort of treasure Blair wick
basement victim oh now it's scary like
you didn't know that it was happening in
the baby's room until she cried go slip
the door open so that it could cruelly
close it in Renee's face at the perfect
time this situation isn't scary unless
you see a door close by itself tony was
oh is still pissed about Lisa cheating
on it boobie doesn't cater to my male
gazing hot ghosts lesbian on hot
Living bicurious milf or wish
fulfillment it's been a long time
Lorraine apparently knows every single
legitimate medium in the world Alfa's
contact her everybody come on just
happens to be dumber than everyone
else's Yahtzee I suppose I should
explain sometimes contacts and by
sometimes I mean all the time are you
third time's a charm she was just out
smoking cigarettes the other two times
do not break the circle don't break the
circle cliche although to be honest I'm
not quite sure one ghost care so much
about geometry
I could easily randomly throw dice and
get a yes out of it I've proven this
time after time during boggle sessions
Elise's ghost plays the pronoun game in
the most frustrating way possible
through dice so the car will have to ask
who the hell she means through dice
where is she I might be a little upset
with this ghost because of the vagueness
but I think it's just the limits of this
dice game why doesn't he have like 300
dice so she can be more specific or
better yet a program on a computer that
throws graphic representations of dice
that the ghost can manipulate using
electronic waves oh I'm the one that's
stupid you say tell us where to find
your killer
I seriously doubt that he has enough
dice to spell even this but I'm a little
more upset about how this scene is
almost three minutes of dice throwing
abandoned haunted Hospital cliche it's
not a James Wan movie without a creepy
Dolph and everything up Karl sees ghosts
MTV music video style somehow Josh's mom
and the other nurse didn't see this old
man get up I just rode down in the
elevator with him he should be in bed on
the monitor with Loraine that patient
died yesterday morning to his death
somehow the story of the old man's
horrible suicide didn't make it to the
rain no one called her and no one
mentioned it despite the fact that she's
been working at the hospital all day
amateur dentistry one's just frightening
it troubles me to the core how much
ghosts play the pronoun game now I admit
this is probably because Josh knows who
the voice is talking about but I think
it's more because the ghost is a
screenwriter who doesn't want to give
away the name yet they want what you
have
life well someone's all poltergeist you
don't that's my song a song I wrote for
you how is it the Josh remembers pretty
much everything except this one vital
thing that gives him away movie decides
to blur which its way through the
haunted house scenes don't you think
that's racist also do you not remember
that the guy tried to castrate himself
this clue could not have hit you in the
head any cleaner it's a horror movie so
of course rocking horses those two
continued the preferred turned around
state when they appeared at this point
we really don't know what this demons
powers are it's been with people for two
movies but she killed Elise and that's
the only person she's killed she has it
made Josh kill his family yet but
apparently his youthful good looks are
tied to it I'm just really confused
right now
demon goes to science at dr. Dalton
through the tin can telephone because
it's stupider that way okay goddamnit
this movie is trying to beat Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows for the
most pronoun game usage ever people have
proper names they use them all the time
this movie is addictive proper names
that's just Lisa she jumped the gun
we're supposed to be a team Lisa I'm so
confused by the motivations of these
ghosts was that girl just a distraction
I mean why did they send a scout before
coming out as a gang you're trying a
Reacher but you won't and let me tell
you why this movie's use of the pronoun
game is so egregious because there are
multiple characters we're trying to keep
straight as a guy who wanted to be a
woman who killed women there's a demon
woman who could possibly be that same
guy or not and there's a lease I'm
pretty sure fake josh is talking to
normal Josh about Elise here but this is
beyond exhausting Patrick Wilson is
walking tall honestly they could have
just dispensed with the surprise of this
long ago and it would have been a lot
more effective we already knew Josh
wasn't himself because he'd been a
dumbass this whole movie also this would
have been an excellent opening to the
movie and every time fake Josh showed up
around Renee and the kids we'd feel the
tension why did you bring us here
probably didn't work because he's not a
circle right now also dice clearly
spelled out Rick's um which if you don't
know what that means I'm not gonna tell
you
movie clearly calls for the ghost of
dobby to put the chandelier but due to
copyrights he was unable to actually
show up in the film moore's blood death
because ghosts suddenly decide that
latin is the best way to communicate at
this point did the dos know that
lorraine was coming in here and was
gonna stand on this very spot you're not
only sorry evil ghost tells the truth
and karl wastes time figuring out
something he already knew more seriously
it's literal it simply means the mother
Parker crane Parker crane is death I
thought he was simply a serial killer
does that mean the mothers of John Wayne
Gacy Jeffrey Dahmer Charles Manson and
Ted Bundy were also the mothers of death
oh yeah sure no it's scary
if she related to the woman in black
right and black claims is 15 feet um if
the killer is a bride and black that
pronoun is her not him oh come on
this guy has that kind of power now the
guy throws dice he killed first mother
because she forced him to he wanted his
childhood back that's why he went after
your son
so as an old man he woke up from a coma
because he since Josh next doing in a
hospital bed and said now's the time
Renee Laurene decides to be a jump-scare
dick rather than going through the
motions of normal conversation to talk
to her daughter-in-law it's not the
house
it's Josh evil demon spirit apparently
makes Josh wake up but only after the
people she wanted to kill are long gone
the code word is quesadilla save me I
thought we agreed on unicorn as the code
word I know you guys are nerds and this
is all comic relief but there's no way
you guys had this conversation and
settled on a code word without arguing
this same argument you're having now
wait this tooth is still sitting out
here in the open he just pulled that
tooth out and threw it on the floor and
no one saw it
first off gross second off wouldn't it
be wise when you're dealing with spirits
and not wanting to get caught doing
paranormal investigations not to hold
the tooth up in full view like this this
further illustrates why you should not
prepare syringes in people's living
rooms Josh is possessed by a psycho
demon and is probably going to kill this
guy but still needs to bother with the
subterfuge why don't you ask you guys
what I have behind my back evil spirit
continues to be evil to the audience by
indulging in Carl's dice games
what is Josh what is Parker crane
holding behind his back would Parker's
mom not have answered the question if
Carl had said Josh also did Josh holding
a knife behind his back require any
goddamn suspense whatsoever I think
would have been scarier if the dice
spelled out giant 12 injured ildo she
was always right oh yeah now it's scary
you just heard Carl Collin Parker crane
you've been unicorn or quesadilla idiots
Jenna nice but I'm going to throw this
cup of you first because murder requires
foreplay man that lantern has guardians
of the galaxy strength batteries doesn't
that thing is going to murder my family
get back honestly I'm just thankful he
waited so long what's up with that
anyway come on you got the answers I'm
getting weaker the longer I'm away from
my body the fact that will surely have
no bearing on the rest of this movie but
let's just say it so it sounds like a
major problem it's got your bravery
baby these guys may be scary helpful
people this point is something Andy has
the Guinness Book of World Records
longest arm for someone shorter than six
feet tall records okay so this is from
the first insidious and the movie's
going to reuse a lot of footage adding
context to the first movie I admit it's
pretty cool but why does Josh get to go
back in time funny Josh didn't hear that
in this movie or in the last one also
why didn't he just keep pounding on the
door at least ex machina these spirits
can physically touch things and
manipulate them in the real world but
this window smashing didn't happen in
the first movie unless they're saying
this only happened in the spirit world
which is bullshit I'm all for this plot
development it gives the first insidious
some interesting wrinkles but since some
of this didn't happen it's sort of like
a round peg trying to fit into square
hole I wish I could say it's good to see
you why didn't you find Josh earlier
what's your ghost attracted by the
disturbance in the force the fuck but I
came back here because I heard you
calling it just took me forever because
you needed to be in a life-or-death
situation before I could actually make
it to your general area maybe we're
asking the wrong Josh so let's go back
in time again I bet it's just a left
turn past the McDonald's and we're in
1986 presto change-o so that's funny
line but I bet you knew even before you
got here what that was about
also you guys are just gonna keep this
time-traveling thing a secret inflicted
on others but for some reason a crisis
of conscience prevented me from doing it
until the climax of the film also Parker
recites a whole soliloquy which gives
Laraine and Renee time to move a whole
goddamn piano in front of the door to
prevent it from coming in okay so that
whole piano thing didn't even matter as
it turns out are we saying that his
demon power allows him to push the door
open with the whole piano in front of it
the guy barely held back an old man
trying to stick him with a syringe
earlier I didn't want this but I'm going
to go through a lot of trouble to
explain it anyway I'm a psycho killer
let's do the one act of murder that
takes the longest amount of time you
didn't hear these kids come in they open
the door and shut the door and this kid
didn't start screaming until his brother
had time to find a baseball bat and
sneak up behind you it's plot
convenience Renee locks this door and
I'm dubious a door inside the house has
a lock like this for any reason but
whatever the house proceeds to make even
less sense as Jon simply walks to the
next
fines renee immediately who is for some
reason stumbling around the room trying
to get to another door when she should
be long gone already
so wait young Josh pointed them to a
door in his old house which led them
straight to perc or cranes house but in
the real world these two houses are far
apart from each other so what makes them
so close in the further why is the
further so bright now young man I guess
they went back in time again but I don't
know how walking through a door in 1986
suddenly takes you back to what year is
this I'm gonna say the 1930s why does
the further take you back to the
absolute seminal moments in this plots
history oh you're just now noticing
these two they were directly in front of
your son a minute ago it took screaming
to turn the lights out in the further
also where did Josh go Oh
Josh is in a place I can go to sleep on
cue
they taught me that at Juilliard aren't
these dead women in an entirely
different room when the rain and the
scooby-doo gang were in this house
earlier also where's the door where they
can just run into the kids bedroom in a
completely different house willy-nilly
is there any sort of geometry to this
cooking place these assholes are just
now waking up and aren't dead why is
Josh doing this what purpose does it
serve to keep pulling the sheets off
these women is he hoping to find a
dimensional warp under one of these
sheets oh so I'm the crazy one you mean
the plot in the 1930s in the plot the
modern-day are converging together
that's so unexpected also does this mean
that the kid didn't end up killing all
those women did they change the future
with this I felt your heart beat when I
hugged you you're still alive and
somehow I made it into the further
because of your dice I guess oh I have
the world's longest tin can telephone
ready to guide us back did you find Josh
in his kid are getting mi beads so they
don't remember this so tell me can I
hire Karl to movie invents a way to keep
Alise doing the exact same thing she did
when she was living which is basically
like saying she didn't die at all
obvious sequel is obvious
Morris black death
okay Santa goddamn we're gonna be okay
see the dip you're right I hate this
like the torch room but this room is
also where the doppelgangers have been
recorded yeah I'd really like to talk to
whoever is impersonating Rebecca and her
son the doppelganger is such an
interesting but pretty far out
paranormal you know at least we are
calling out to you tell us if you are
there